- You smell nice.
- You too.
- Yeah I know.
(pop music)
- Hi my name is Kramer Cruz.
- Hello my name is Kara Anthony.
- We had been together for about a year,
just over a year.
And as the relationship got more serious
obviously she wanted
more and more commitment.
I just wasn't really ready to do that.
- When I signed up for this
and decided to do this game,
I thought, oh it'll be fine,
we're still cool, we could work together.
But actually the anxiety that
has come about doing this
today is a little overwhelming,
it's a little somber.
- Hey my name is Quinn Knox.
- Hi I'm Leo Valez.
- We dated for I guess about six months.
Things got a little too comfortable
and we just decided that it was best
not to see each other anymore.
- We were very mature about it,
so we talked it out, and
we tried to make it work.
But once the fire is
gone, it's kind of hard
to reignite it, and that's something that
I think should come naturally.
I hope to at least keep him in my life
because Quinn's a great guy.
To have him involved
would be a great thing,
he's someone I really value.
- I don't understand
exactly why it broke off.
I don't think he does either,
but I'm open for new experiences.
- [Leo] It's all coming back to me now.
- [Quinn] Okay we can
just leave your shoes.
I'm like, OCD.
- [Leo] Conservative start.
(laughter)
- [Kramer] Oh, okay good that's easy.
Oh.
- [Leo] Oh no.
Spiderman!
- Do I have to keep this one up?
(laughter)
I'll push you over.
- [Leo] Yeah that's the rule of the,
(laughter)
- I feel like I'm doing yoga.
- [Quinn] You're inching away from me.
- I did not do this wisely.
- You look so Spiderman-ish.
(groaning)
(laughter)
- Okay you did that on purpose.
You kicked me.
(laughter)
- I knew I was gonna win.
Yay!
- [Leo] Oh god.
- I don't know that we're gonna
be playing anymore Twister.
(laughter)
We get very competitive with each other
and I think that was one
of the problems maybe.
But I don't know it was kind of nice.
I mean its...
- Keeps you on your toes.
- I think it's difficult,
you know, with relationships
like how you move forward if you stay,
if it can continue or
if it just breaks off.
And so I don't know, for
me this confirmed that
we still have good chemistry regardless of
whatever happens in the future.
- Like in the beginning
I felt some rigidness,
you know it was awkward, with
the silence and everything.
But as we got into the game,
something about the game,
the atmosphere of a game at all,
kind of lowered my guard a little bit.
- I mean I'd like to think
that just being here today
and having this experience
could open the doors
for us to just even talk
about it after this.
- Congratulations for winning.
- Oh thank you.
(laughter)
(happy music)